I am going to submit for your review
today what I believe could be the most
shameful moment of the Trump
administration so far and it's an
interview of Katrina Pierson appearing
on Fox News and straight up lying to ed
Henry's face repeatedly boldly
confidently about known facts that are
on audio recording so let me catch you
up about all this this relates to the
Trump n-word recordings which seem to be
bringing out the absolute worst pathetic
lying in everybody who's surrounding
Trump it started when former Trump staff
for Omarosa Manigault rump using the
n-word when talking about black people
and she also specifically said that
Trump campaign advisor Katrina Pierson
is on one of these recordings talking
about how should they spin how can they
spin Donald Trump's use of the n-word
Katrina Pierson appeared on Fox News
Monday night I've already told you about
this and when she appeared on Monday
night she said no such tape exists no I
was never party to such a conversation
and no such tape exists but then the
next day Tuesday as you know the
recording was released we've heard a
recording we heard a tape of exactly the
conversation that Katrina Pierson just
hours earlier denied ever having been
party to once again confirming that
she's a bold-faced unabashed liar so Fox
News does what I think is actually the
right thing which is they bring her back
and then ed Henry says hey here's what
you said yesterday
then this tape got released it seems
you're not telling the truth so we're
gonna go through this in pieces here is
my challenge to you try to follow what
she's saying that's it it's a very
simple challenge try to even understand
the recursive and obvious lies that she
tells here let's start digging into it
so apparently Omer Omarosa was watching
us last night because I understand it's
got an email that she told Trevor Noah
at the Daily Show she heard you tell me
you knew nothing about conference call
talking about whether the president used
an n-word you
this was a movie script so she says she
released at least one of these audio
tapes to show you lied to us well look
first of all that's not true as well
so there are two things that occurred
last night in our discussion you had
read for me a book EPS excerpt that I
had not seen because her book had not
come out yet and you referenced me
having been speaking to the president
about this issue and that is false
okay so let's let's stop right there so
right away she's reading this written
statement and she miss reads it and she
talks about an ex Turk and she tries to
change the discussion from whether she
had a conference call about Trump's and
word news new use to whether she spoke
to Trump about his n-word use this is
the theme answering questions that were
not actually asked by Ed Henry
commenting on things that Henry doesn't
even mention and Ed Henry bless him he
tries to short-circuit it and he decides
to jump in and play the clip from the
previous night but see if you can even
follow this nonsense okay so let me get
to the facts I don't want to get to side
issues bottom line is you're saying
there's one call with Jason Miller one
without Jason Miller let's get to Miller
in a second the one without Jason Miller
on CBS Omarosa says according to a
transcript you provided me a part they
have not aired yet Omarosa says yeah
it's out there meaning the n-word tape
it's just in Katrina Pierson cuts in
yeah he said it ah bleep okay that is a
rough roughly what she said in the book
that you cursed as I asked you last
night and you said he said it he used
the n-word you denied that to me
absolutely you know why because I'm
refuting a claim that Omarosa made and
I'll say it again on Chuck Todd and
Savannah Guthrie let's not talk about
Chuck done we just talked about this
date I'm gonna be polite to you but no
no I'm not gonna do citations pardon me
ed Henry's trying right I mean he is
trying to not let her talk about other
shows and other things because he
doesn't want to talk about that stuff he
wants an answer to here's how amorosa
described your participation in her book
and it matches up exactly to the
transcript
of the release tape that we now have and
you've been denying all of it all along
these are obvious lies and she just
wants to talk about other things and it
continues take a look we were talking
that is not the question that you were
asking me this was in regards to a
specific discussion check the tapes of
what she said on Chuck Todd and Savannah
Guthrie she specifically said that I
said and confirmed that Donald Trump
said a derogatory term on a conference
call with Jason Miller that did not
happen what happened what happened today
is Omarosa submitted two different tapes
to CBS I'm not gonna get sidetracked but
we have to I will admit there's two tips
I'm gonna explain it would almost be
better to just deny having been on Fox
News on Monday right when he says listen
you were on here last night and you said
she should say I wasn't on this show I
wasn't here isn't FoxNews supposed to be
a safe space for these people apparently
not it's the minimum it's just hey you
were on and you said this
it's the obfuscation and then he read
Henry he tries to get really direct he
points out that at one point she said
she admitted that Trump used the n-word
but it was just to move on okay
can you imagine that admitting that the
boss used the n-word about black people
even though they really didn't because
you just wanted to get on to another
topic of conversation who would do that
and if that's true that should be the
discussion so here's the next portion of
this I'm gonna lead this discussion and
the fact of the matter is today you
clarified and said no I just said yes he
moved he used the n-word because I
wanted to move the conversation along
that was a discussion okay there's
multiple discussions why don't you if
that's the truth why didn't you tell me
and you know I don't know all the
details of this book I haven't seen it
but I did say yes he used the n-word to
move the conversation along it didn't
say that was the story question I was
asked about this conference call with
Jason Miller the answer is no that was
not said the transcript is right here
both calls this
the first call that you're talking about
where she's claiming that I said that
was in a totally different call where
she was arguing with Linden's about the
existence of this let me explain
something to you
Omarosa has been using this tape to
manipulate people she is a bully she is
pushy she has a dog with a bone with
this let's go to facts and not attacks
this is just unconscionable and once
again she's there trying to defend the
indefensible as I said earlier she might
as well have just denied that she ever
made any claims or even appeared on fox
news because it's just as unbelievable
and then she goes into what works for
Trump which is not only criticizing and
smearing Omarosa but even criticizing
her and smearing her with the same word
dog let's look at just a little bit of
this let's get to the substance on that
call you say in your statement today
that basically we were just sifting
through rumors and the Jason Miller call
he was a campaign aide in fact we have
the transcript that you provided okay
and here's what is on the tape Jason
Miller says it's kind of tough to go out
and draft something meaning a statement
about whether the president use the
n-word when you don't even know what the
context is you know I hate to start
emailing stuff around when we're just
not that sifting through rumors guess
what Katrina Pearson says yes it's true
so you that's true you don't want to go
around making these accusations I'm
coming up with say mrs. drew it was very
true just miss Corder yourself you just
said I said that's true
no you said it's true this is the best
Katrina Pierson comes in okay she hands
a transcript of the call it's her
transcript hurt her reading of the call
to Ed Henry Edie Henry reads it and says
here's what your transcript says you
said she goes that's not what I said
Katrina it's your transcript there is no
more shame than this and this is part of
you know the alternative fact stuff the
post truth era call it whatever you want
she could have started at the beginning
and said you know I don't remember such
a conversation well I just I just don't
remember it could the conversation I
have a million conversations during the
campaign she could have said almost
anything but in
said she said that conversation was
never party to such a conversation and
you know that Trump's gonna add insult
to injury too right he's going to scold
her for not defending him well enough
for not denying that Trump ever used the
n-word strongly enough for getting
caught in these web of lies well you
have to assume she knows Trump is
watching and at some point at some point
we'll see it and by the way side note if
you look at this clip I just played for
you on Fox News's YouTube channel the
comments are just slamming at Henry as
if he's the problem here and not the
unabashed lying reality and truth do not
matter anymore